il est 9h15 j'essaie de me connecter
pour les accueillir dans ma salle de
classe et et on ne peut pas se connecter
aurélie diédhiou et professeur de
lettres classiques ce mercredi matin
elle essaye de se connecter tant bien
que mal à la plateforme en ligne pronote
hier mardi 7 avril
une panne informatique a bloqué
l'environnement de travail de nombreux
élèves franciliens aujourd'hui difficile
encore de faire grâce à la maison c'est
juste très compliqué parce que voilà
parce que la plateforme ne marche pas
forcément moi j'ai besoin de mes élèves
j'ai besoin de voilà de de les avoir en
face c'est un métier de communication
suis pas devenue enseignante pour avoir
une machine en face de moi j'ai besoin
de l'humain en fait après 30 minutes
d'aléas techniques le cours peut
commencer
le thème de la séance aujourd'hui le
théâtre de l'absurde
angèle c'est sur trente élèves ils
seront finalement 12 à s'être connectés
et aurélie ziz y aura parlé en tout un
quart d'heure heureusement les
professeurs ont eu deux jours avant la
fermeture pour organiser le travail et
donner des polycopiés les professeurs
entre eux cèdent également avec ce
nouveau mode de travail
on a mis en place des fausses classe
virtuelle et puis aller le collègue
faisait les élèves
on a vraiment mutualisé notre expérience
parce qu'on a découvert l'année dernière
il ya un an à nouveau métier quand on
est tous devenus enseignants n'est pas
devenu enseignant pour être là à la
maison ça a été très dur l'année
dernière pour beaucoup de mes collègues
pour moi aussi de nous retrouver du jour
au lendemain sans personne son élève
devant nous autre difficulté pour cette
professeure gérer ses propres enfants
mère de deux adolescents la vie à la
maison est parfois compliqué ici bas
voilà comme comme tout le monde j'ai mes
enfants donc ils sont dans leur coin ils
sont avec ordinateur on se retrouve pour
déjeuner défendant décalé et puis des
fois ça marche pas chez nous donc c'est
branle-bas-de-combat tous avec toi petit
nos petits problèmes
seul avantage des cours à distance les
professeurs n'ont pas le trajet école
maison à faire la place à la maison se
poursuivra jusqu'à vendredi avant deux
semaines de vacances et reprendra une
semaine après les vacances pour les
collégiens et lycéens